Question Is it
appropriate for law enforcement
to monitor social media
to prevent and solve crimes?
I ask because here in Philadelphia
this week, parts of the city
were ransacked
by widespread smash and grab looting.
The thieves targeted clothing and sneaker
shops, high
end stores, wine and spirits
shops, pharmacies and an Apple Store.
Police say the agitators organize
their plans on social media.
Among the more than 50 folks
arrested was an influencer.
Deja Blackwell, known as Meatball
According to police,
she livestreamed the ransacking
and broadcast,
which stores and locations to loot
That's not funny.
The cops come and they go
which means we're going
for the second suite
We're
everybody's lucky.
Everybody must be outraged by the
she was later arrested
after what
the Philadelphia
Inquirer dubbed a digital cat
and mouse game with police.
She now faces eight charges,
including criminal conspiracy and riot.
She declined CNN's request for comment,
but later told a local TV station
that her lawyer had advised her
not to do interviews.
What happened in Philadelphia
isn't alone. Incident.
Not a one off.
Cities across
the country
are working to combat
organized retail crime
and performance crime,
where perpetrators
often brag about their actions
on social media,
with more people posting crimes
publicly online or using social media
as a criminal tool.
Police departments are stressing
the importance
of ramping up surveillance
so that they can monitor accounts
for threats or criminal activity.
But they're facing stiff opposition
from civil liberty advocates
who say that it's
just another way for the government
to infringe on your right to privacy.
Take Boston as just one example.
In 2016,
the city wanted to spend $1.4 million
to beef up its social media monitoring
Butt kicked it down the road
after backlash from the ACLU,
who said that
it would chill free speech
and could target communities
already subjected to extra scrutiny,
including Muslims and people of color.
New York has ramped up their monitoring,
even signing a contract
with a company that uses
AI to monitor online behavior.
And in 2021,
a public records request
by the Brennan Center
found the Los Angeles Police Department
authorizes its officers to engage
in extensive surveillance of social media
without internal monitoring.
Of the nature
or effectiveness of the searches.
The LAPD responded by saying
that it works to keep residents
safe and is committed
to protecting their privacy rights
as we confront the challenge every day.
With me now
to discuss is Pfizer Patel,
the senior director of the Liberty
and National Security Program
at the Brennan Center for Justice
Thank you so much for being here.
To me,
it seems natural, intuitive, logical
that law enforcement
would be following
the social media accounts
of individuals
they know are suspect or involved
in this kind of activity.
And if they say, you know,
we're headed to the Apple Store
on Walnut Street,
police ought to be there to meet them.
What am I getting wrong?
You're not getting anything wrong.
It's just that that's not what.
Well,
that's not the only thing that police use
social media for. And that's the problem.
So if you think about investigating
a crime, for example.
Right,
you know, of some kind of a criminal ring
that is posting things on social media
that might be relevant
to your investigation.
Of course,
the cops should be able to look at that.
If you know
that there is a protest
or a demonstration organized somewhere
and the cops want to know, well,
how many people do
we need to have out there?
What is the potential
that things might get out of hand?
What is our resource allocation?
Absolutely.
You need to be able to look
at social media to do that.
Unfortunately,
because the rules are so lax
Police
also use social media to monitor
protest movements.
You mentioned the Boston
Police Department's attempt to buy,
you know,
a $1.4 million contract
for social media monitoring.
Why did it get.
Why did it get derailed?
In part
because evidence came out that the BPD
was actually monitoring
Black Lives Matter hashtags
as well as what they called
hashtag Muslim
Lives Matter
and other political,
religious and racial protests.
Categories.
The same thing is true with the LAPD.
It's not that we were worried
that they're going to be using it
to solve crimes.
We were worried because we found evidence
that they were using it
to monitor protest activities.
So what if there's overlap
between the two, between what's at
Pfizer?
What if there's
overlap between the two in the examples
that you articulated
or in a hypothetical where, okay,
there's a group
that seemingly is involved
in some social justice profile
but there's reason to believe
that there will be trouble afoot
from some of its members. Then what?
Then I think you do have the ability
to monitor it in that context,
but you have to have rules around it.
And I think that's where
most police departments fall down,
which is that the rules
that they have are very permissive.
They are just like,
oh, social media monitoring is useful.
You're allowed to do it.
But in fact,
if you're monitoring for public safety
purposes, say,
you know, to
figure out what resources you need
at a protest or where you might be afraid
that there might be some violence,
then once that protest is done,
you don't need to keep that data anymore.
You don't need to be creating dossiers
on activists and protesters. Right.
So it's really a question of how
to make sure
that police can use
social media
as an effective crime-fighting jewel,
but not use it to infringe on people's
First Amendment rights.
You're reminding me of a reason I'm doing
I'm on the fly here,
but I think I'm
right over the last couple of years,
there was a
there was a Supreme Court case.
Tell me if you think that this is
fair for comparison.
And it said that if Pfizer Patel
is driving down the street
law enforcement can follow you
as you go about your business in public.
But in order to place
a GPS tracker on your car,
there's going to have to be a showing
and a warrant
So how does that compare to this?
Because like this individual
who's been charged
in Philadelphia
with 185,000 Instagram followers
you know,
is very publicly allegedly
making the case.
Here's where we should go.
Here's what we want to hear next.
And so in my analysis,
that's the case of law enforcement
following you down the street.
They shouldn't need to do anything.
They should be able to follow her
like any of the other
nearly 200,000 people
So I think one of the
things to understand
about surveillance technology
over the last couple of decades
is that it has changed dramatically.
Right.
When we used to think about surveillance,
we would think about wiretaps. Right.
I call you.
And if the police want to listen in,
they need to get a warrant.
Now, what we're looking at more
and more is public surveillance. Right.
Which is the ability of technology
to track people
generally without their knowing through,
you know,
cell phone, GPS
those kinds of technologies.
Social media falls
in a slightly different place
because in those instances,
you're not actively trying
to reveal your location to anybody
you're just walking down the street.
Right.
Whereas social media,
you're actually
putting information out there.
So I think it is reasonable
to allow police access to social media.
But at the same time,
we need to make sure
that we have protections in place
so that that access is not used
to monitor protesters and people who are
you know, I get it.
I get it.
Let me let me just say
by way of example
and put this up on the screen,
it's from The Philadelphia Inquirer
this week about what
just went on here blocks
from where I'm seated.
I mean, this is
this was some of what was being said
in social media,
what time we go
in, quote unquote, shopping,
we looting or not
I know they say tearing up our stuff
ain't right.
But that's the only way they hear us.
I mean, I'm
just hoping that there's a cop
with a smartphone in a police van
you know, on patrol
who is also following this
and saying, aha,
here's where we need to go next.
You get the final word.
What did you most want to
say in 30 seconds?
I think that
social media
monitoring can be a useful tool
for fighting crime,
but I think it's really,
really important
that police departments
have clear standards and safeguards
so that that tool is not turned
against Americans
exercising their First Amendment rights.
Pfizer Patel,
thank you so much for being here.